good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight hope you had a terrific
fourth of july it's a day worth
celebrating despite what you may
read day in and day out this is still a
great country
where else you're going to go that's
better nowhere america is still full of
happy
decent independent-minded people the
attitudes of our leaders may have
changed dramatically in recent years and
they have
but the virtues of our population have
not changed that's the good news
the bad news is the people in charge are
working hard to make americans hate our
own country
if you made the mistake of going online
this weekend you saw them pouring out
their misery on social media
instead of enjoying hot dogs and
fireworks with the kids they don't have
they were on twitter yelping about
slavery and white supremacy and what a
terrible place the united states is
it's easy to ignore people like this you
just turn off your screen and then go
live your life
unfortunately it is much harder to
shield your children from them
that's the problem case in point last
week the largest teachers union in the
country the national education
association
announced that its new and first
priority is making anti-american
indoctrination race-based indoctrination
mandatory in every classroom in the
country all k
through 12 schools the union declared
must teach children that
quote white supremacy anti-blackness
anti-indigeneity racism patriarchy
cis heteropatriarchy capitalism ableism
and anthrocentrism
are embedded in every aspect of american
society
so if you're a straight white american
even if you're a very small child
you are guilty it's your fault you're a
bad person
that's what teachers will be telling
your children this fall
the teachers union ended this statement
with this line which is so hilariously
revealing that it does belong in a
museum somewhere and we hope it makes it
quote as the ancient african proverb
says
know thyself the african proverb
except it's not an african proverb no
thyself is of course
greek as an illiterate person knows it
was inscribed by the ancient greeks
in the temple of apollo at delphi but
the teachers union the teachers union
did not know this
so not only these people crazed
ideologues they are
stupid your children are being taught by
some of the most
ignorant people in the country how'd
that happen
god knows how it happened but you better
not complain about it or else joe
biden's praetorian guard will denounce
you on television
as a racist but the former vice
president tonight also
joining the rest of the gop pushing
false
right-wing talking points about the
teaching of critical race
theory gates and the other trumpers want
critical race theory
to just be a foghorn they're no more dog
whistles
this is about the woke left making the
white man
pay for things claims of reverse racism
have been the bread and butter of the
modern republican party for decades
and now they have a new boogeyman to
latch on to critical race theory
it's a boogie man it's not real you
imagined it you're crazy
despite the fact that teachers union
just spelled out in a document calling
for more yes critical race theory
but if you notice that if you object in
any way
to the current obsession with race the
one subject no normal person really
wants to obsess over
then you yourself are obsessed with race
and you must be stopped because you're
dangerous
that's what they're saying not just a
few of them all of them are saying that
and as always they're saying it in
unison
so what does the average person do about
this what does it take to fight back
against it and of course you should be
fighting back against it because
everything is at stake you can't have
a multi-racial democracy if people
retreat into their tribes and hate each
other
as this curriculum teaches them to do so
what do you do well whatever you do it's
going to take some courage
daniel concannon learned that the hard
way until a few weeks ago con cannon was
an administrator
at northwest elementary school in
manchester new hampshire
like so many school employees he was
then forced to participate
in training about the fundamental moral
flaws inherent to white people
as an american and a normal person
someone who admires martin luther
king he objected to this on the other
hand
he like most people had very little
power to do anything about it he wasn't
a rich person he was making about 30
grand a year he needed the job
but in the end his conscience would not
allow him to participate
in something this poisonous so he
resigned and if you get a minute look up
his resignation letter it's online
he ends it this way quote i wish the
trotsky disciples at manchester school
district nothing but
failure in their ongoing quest for
civilizational degradation
i leave you with the only verbal
response befitting an attempt at
anti-white indoctrination
fu well it wasn't so long ago that
daniel concannon and men
and women like him would have been
considered heroes he's a man of
conscience he was willing to
sacrifice his own job to do the right
thing but he's not considered a hero
anymore in fact he's been effectively
disappeared you may not have heard his
name
until tonight there aren't a lot of
daniel con cannons out there
and that's the point the few that arise
are muted
so that no one will follow them
corporate media has no interest in
amplifying their stories
or the story of this guy this man is a
father who showed up at a school board
meeting recently in illinois
and decided to tell a few obvious truths
here's what he said
you're gonna deliberately teach kids
this white kid right here
got it better than you because he's
white you're gonna personally tell a
white kid oh
the black people are all down and
suppressed how do i have two medical
degrees if i'm sitting here oppressed
how do i get first of all you've only
got five minutes now
five minutes two medical degrees no mom
no dad in the house work my way through
college sat there and hustled my butt
off to get through cops you're gonna
tell me somebody look like all your
white folks
kept me from doing that are you serious
i do this stuff on a daily basis i'm in
the hood
i'm in the communities i'm out there
with folks in their face i've been doing
stuff since i was 18 years old talking
to black folks you know what
none of them are buying this nonsense
and that not one
white person ever don't keep any of them
from getting there
so the crt stuff bs
must be one of those alt-right q queuing
on people cnn's always warning you about
it's bs he said
and you heard the applause in the
background the overwhelming majority of
americans and
pollsters have found this pretty clearly
think this is insane
they think you should judge people by
what they do not on the basis
of their skin color they believe in
martin luther king so it is bs in fact
it's more than that
it's civilization ending poison but it's
everywhere how widespread is it well we
can't really be sure
until we finally get cameras in the
classroom as we put them on the chest of
police officers until we finally get a
civilian
review board in every town in america to
oversee the people
teaching your children forming their
minds and let's hope we get both of
those very soon
but until we do we can't know exactly
how widespread this is
but there are indications we know that
these ideas this poison has made it all
the way to expensive private schools in
central ohio
columbus academy among them columbus
academy one of the most prestigious
schools in the state of ohio
tuition more than 30 grand a year per
student
in the past year columbus academy which
has a long history of academic
excellence
has become race obsessed school
administrators aren't working to help
unwed teenage mothers or improve black
neighborhoods that might actually make
the country better
if you want to talk about race maybe you
could improve someone's life but they're
not
instead they're doing what all guilty
white liberals do they've adopted the
same familiar racist curriculum
some people are better than other people
based on the color of their skin
they've been teaching that and a lot of
parents went along with it they didn't
say a word they didn't know what was
happening
or they were too afraid to speak up but
two mothers decided
they weren't going to have it so they
objected their names are andrea gross
and amy gonzalez
and in january they decided we're going
to fight this we love this school and
we're going to do something about it
so they founded a group called the pro
columbus academy coalition and it was
pro columbus academy
they wanted to make the school better
their mission was to stop the bigotry
and return columbus academy to its
academic mission
teaching children to read teaching them
history
showing them how to do math but the
people who run columbus academy
didn't want to hear it they didn't want
to have the conversation they didn't
want to listen
they wanted gross and gonzales to shut
up and go away
but they wouldn't when you make a mother
mad about her children
it's hard to make her shut up so last
month
instead of punishing them the school
decided to punish their children
columbus academy
kicked their three daughters out of
school they expelled them for what their
mothers did
so challenge the regime and will hurt
your children the soviets did it
columbus academy did it too the school's
headmistress that confirmed mediocrity
called melissa soderbergh
sent a letter to every parent in the
school explaining why she was punishing
the children for the sins of the parents
but she didn't write it alone that
letter was signed by the head of the
board someone you'd think might know
better a local developer called jonathan
cass someone with a job
but he signed it according to soderberg
and cass
by daring to complain about racism in
the columbus academy
curriculum which is real these two
mothers had caused quote
pain and even fear for physical safety
among students
families faculties and staff in other
words
if you dare to question us we won't
disagree with you
we'll attack you we'll hurt your
children and we'll accuse you
of assault it's a physical crime
you're making us afraid hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else